decenas de miles de personas salieron a
las calles de londres para protestar
contra la congelación salarial y los
recortes de empleo en el sector público
entre ellos está a matt harding que
lleva 25 años conduciendo los trenes del
metro de londres la huelga es la única
forma que tiene de hacer oír su voz los
trabajadores del ferrocarril o cualquier
otro necesitan al menos un 10% para
mantenerse en contacto con la inflación
y creo que está está muy por debajo de
lo que la gente necesita como conductor
marcan a casi seis mil euros al mes un
buen sueldo pero ese es el doble de los
ingresos medios de un trabajador
ferroviario
si se van a recortar miles y miles de
puestos de trabajo de mantenimiento y se
van a subcontratar a personas menos
formadas va a ser un peligro
scania
marc se jubila en agosto con 60 años son
los más jóvenes los que le preocupan
el gobierno el señor boris johnson
quiere cerrar el fondo de pensiones este
hombre quiere impedir que la gente se
retire del metro con dignidad
las conversaciones entre las empresas
ferroviarias y el principal sindicato se
han estancado
nuestras compañías operadoras de trenes
no lo han anunciado pero van a cerrar
todas las taquillas de todas las
estaciones de reino unido me lo han
dicho cara a cara quieren recortar la
restauración el personal de los trenes
no podemos aceptarlo esta economía y
este ferrocarril van hacia atrás pues
para muchos de estos manifestantes la
huelga es ahora la única orden del día
aunque los usuarios del transporte
paguen el precio